hello my name is Anton Tov
I'm going to talk about conversational
agents for neural networks but more
generally for machine learning machine
learning workflows and algorithms I'm
using version 12 because I wanted to put
this conversational agents talk I was
thinking to hook up Alexa and show you
stuff but actually the speech recognizer
in what version 12 this topic I wanted
to use I still unfortunately doesn't
parse my voice about well but I hope I
can if we have time I'm going to show
you how it works so what I'm trying to
do is that's why because I'm using
version 12 the preview list that's why
it's not exactly the slideshow it it
crashes but you know I'm going to use
the scrolling presentation in some
extent I like it better so what I'm
trying to do is not to make end-user
end-user conversational agent for
classification or whatever I actually
want to have a conversational agents but
generates generates code and this code
we can take it and elaborated further so
this is a conversation and trying to
design conversational agents but help
data scientists machine learning
practitioners or something you know to
generate code and and utilize it further
so here I think this should be live so
what's happening here hopefully and
because the talks about neural network
and training some neural network stopped
it but this here what you see is a
monadic pipeline so I'm going to
elaborate further I just want to give in
the first two minutes very quick
overview of what is the methodology and
presumably after that you might decide
you don't wanna listen go to another
talk so here what we see is a
interleaved code and comments roughly
speaking I'm going to show you how the
comments which in between the executable
code they can be they can be used as a
conversational commands and from these
commands we can generate the code so
there's several things here you might
recognize actually not sure how useful
this is but this table here it comes
from the tracing so this monadic
pipeline here which I generated I just
plug in this thing here to it and this
is my Minari pipeline symbol and you
know we can see a breakdown of the of
the operations so when this is executing
I'm going to execute it again you are
getting you know increasingly you know
proclaiming some results are being
proclaimed it is a pipeline because we
start with the a certain data set here I
wrap the data set into into this tracing
model in order to produce this to be
able to make these comments and then to
produce this table but after after I
have trained a classifier I want to see
the measurements I want to proclaim the
measurements what we see here I want to
see the receive operating
characteristics you know true positive
versus false positive
I want to try to figure out what other
what are the importance of the variables
we can see what passenger sex is most
important for Titanic and you know
basically this is it alright so another
executive summary type of thing so I
start with some data like this and then
so this was classification now if we do
regression actually this is a little bit
more interesting probably this is
actually how this this looks like how
this conversation of agent looks like so
you can see what all of this in some
sense this conversational agent of this
methodology it's like a single line
interpreter each of these commands are
being translated into something this I
think I'm going to demonstrate you
artists it's basically code so if I pick
any of those here for example this I'm
not sure
and what should I do now
DM alright thank you
this was reassuring so yeah you can see
with this I generated new code what is
this new code I mean I said compute net
regression with 420 a box and we can see
their box and whatnot so so basically if
I can gather all these commands and
produce produce code option I'm going to
show you this later actually this by the
way it's a terrible fit from the okay
the plot here which is supposed to be
happening
it's made before now I deleted the whole
thing well let me let me convince you
this is more interactive than a when I
want it to be but if I do it with 20 a
box you can see what corresponds to the
neural network it's actually very poor I
can increase say the box and you know
this is going to to compute it for a
longer period and now I'm going to get
it better or I can say 22,000 a box over
say you know four seconds and so
presumably this is going to train for
four seconds and just going to produce
the result and you can see what now the
the curve which corresponds to the
neural network it's it's better so what
is the big picture on this so we start
with some some sort of problem domain
like say neural networks classification
regression what I was showing basically
I developed to two domain-specific
languages one is a natural language
which is here on the left and another
one is the main specific language in
Mathematica or any other programming
language then I try to because they're
both domain-specific languages using
certain formalism namely monadic
perspective I can actually very easily
map one to the other what I was showing
earlier with interleaved comments and
code it's it should be clear but it does
this correspondence after you have done
this for a while it presumably gets more
mature I can start making different
types of conversational agents and what
we see here is what first is the single
line interpreter I haven't went further
than that then we can try to to make a
lookup of series of commands and do some
kind of optimization like say well it's
not our compilers do and then you can
cook it to some device like a lecture or
Google Chrome whatever
so the general workflow what I'm
describing here is I mean it's pretty
simple in classification we try to we
try to split the data we after we split
the data we train the the classifiers
and then then we try to evaluate what's
going on but this picture below I mean
you can see what the whole thing is much
more elaborated there might be some
assumptions about the data for example
there might be some conditions we might
get wrong result so unsatisfactory
results like what I was doing earlier
with contour regression and we can go
through certain loop so just so it is
much better this is very difficult to
support just with some options and some
variations of one single command it is
much better to have a language which so
what I usually do I develop grammars and
these grammars were being verbalized and
being verbalized I didn't know
programming language or natural language
and then we we make the we make the
domain-specific languages corresponding
to that and further after this is done I
proceed with making the conversational
agents so if you haven't seen what is
Amanat well you can see my presentation
from last year but you have seen it in
one way or the other models have been
used in in different in different type
of form mathematics I apologize about
this not sure what happened maybe I
should have done it but I wanted to make
a wife demo with something called GC so
I think like this so I guess some of you
have figured out what this is this is
the reverse polish notation what we are
having here we having a function free
this function free operates on a stack
and puts the value free on that stack
then we have a function for which puts
on top of the stack of the argument
which the stack value for we have
multiply which takes the top two
elements of the stack and changes it
into one and so forth this P here you're
getting out of the monit so basically
you're it's you're printing out the
results this this is very similar to
what we are going to see in um when we
use when you use layers and so forth
this is not what I have I'm sorry this
is the wrong presentation so it's here
so well when we when we train neural
networks for example let me show you
some way do all I mean this here it's a
clear invitation for for this kind of
specification and I'm going to expand on
this let's say let's go further through
the moment loss and whatnot so I mean
the the why this is this important if
your code has certain algebraic
structures in it so your code here's
algebraic structure you can actually
manipulate this code in a certain way
like do cogeneration do whatever I'm
doing here this is a very powerful
technique very useful few languages can
can utilize it the guy who made Fortran
his name is buck you snore oh sorry John
Backus nor buck you snore formalism is
what I used to do the grammars so john
john backus
for his turing award he wrote a paper
can we get away from the phone Neumann
architecture and programming or
something and so here I was actually
advocating similar stuff using algebraic
putting algebraic properties in your
programming code very few languages as I
said can do it mathematical is one of
them so I mean if you if you look at
this diagram here it's very simple what
we watch is happening every oldest thing
we saw before it's just I can easily
easily pull off with this binding and
symbol matching and pattern matching in
North America so this is what is
happening all right so this is the
single one command interpreter
you can see some other stuff here I mean
it's basically producing some other
things what is interesting here okay so
if I have all of the commands right so I
can produce this this thing here and
then well not sure what exactly okay so
all right yeah this is the important
example which I was promising so you can
see what this is what I was shot earlier
this is how I translate a single line
but if I if I take this if I take this
here this is all of the commands I used
this is code which I can just take and
plug in to something like a tonic and
then I put this code and then I have the
execution so this is what is my goal I
want from this sequence of natural
commands to produce code which I can
later on modify in some way so this is
just for classification but it's
important to keep in mind what neural
networks we don't exist in a vacuum so
we they need to be utilized in some way
and this is basically representing
certain work for which you can see here
from the natural commands we are
splitting the data with rate training
can assemble that's actually interesting
thing here I'm training symbol of
classifiers not just not just one
classifier this is not something it's in
Mathematica but anyway this workflow
which is actually fairly complicated and
it's not trivial to just do so just
training the neural network it gives you
some stuff but you want to execute this
kind of workforce as often as you want
and so one way to store workflows is
actually to use these kind of
specifications as I said this is a
domain-specific language and concise
enough to be used for further stuff all
right so this here it's not important
let's let's look into because it's about
neural networks right now
I haven't plugged in the neural network
classification it
objects into the this classification
moment I did put them in dough into the
quantile regression mode which I was
showing earlier so with the quantile
regression somewhat easier because the
data is simpler and I'm not exactly sure
what is the best way to proceed further
with the management of the grammars and
some other things one of my goals is to
actually discuss this but now let's look
into this this comment which is about
training neural network chain as I said
this is a clear monadic clear monadic
invitation here all these elements here
we are transferring we're transferring
matrices from one to the other that's
why we have names like tensorflow and
whatnot so this is a monadic pipeline so
I can even capitalize on this analogy
like say here with this I made a simple
a simple parser so you can see I have a
I have a parser which parses a layer
right in this this layer and then I can
extend it further in order to be to be
able to person to be able to pass more
than one layer and then actually if I
let me show you what is happening here
so if I do this right if I so I have
this command which I'm using the
pipelining symbol between the between
the layer elements so I'm splitting here
the this this command here I'm splitting
headache' or you know to this pipeline
and I'm doing this now what is happened
you just produced a list of layers
you'll say so what this was to begin
with you know but actually you know here
you see with this application command
this here is a shortcut of Parsa pi so
if I do something like this
I can actually make makeup Parsa which
which basically produces a neural
network so worried what did they change
I just moved from you know I just put
parks apply so this here now all these
strings which were first before this
strings of the layers they turn it into
expression and then I put any chain on
it and then using the fact that
Mathematica can superimpose net chains
so if you do net chain of net chains you
produce a net chain so we get this as
you can see we do have some algebraic
structures in the code so Wolfram
research we have done very good job they
have implemented Amanat for for doing
neural network chain training and not
training just specification in training
so in some sense this is the big message
here so now here like if you look at the
command here's like would be nice to be
able to do some complicated commands
like this like you know an element twice
layer then with tandem convolutional
layer and so forth right so in photo we
might you might want to do other
commands and I have listed some I don't
I haven't implemented all of this some
of ever like wishful thinking but this
actually it's interesting I haven't done
this yet but I am meaning I have done
the grammars I haven't done the
implementations using the most of the
time we are not training new new neural
networks you are just retrieving an
existing network from some repository
like sadovo from repository and then you
are modifying it slightly and then you
are plugging in teen in your big flow
like say the classification workflows I
showed other contour aggression
workflows I showed so this is this is
this is what I'm currently working on so
here this slider this is just going
through different different I mean just
evaluated here I guess it's just showing
how i parse different commands like if
we say list models this is a net
repository query blah blah now what is
happening here is what because
mathematically eskimo iconic meaning
mathematical can interpret its own code
this means but you can actually very
easily hook up to the abstract syntax
trees which come from the parsers very
mathematical code I just need to provide
some implementation behind this
functions and I'm going to have a
functional not just parser I'm going to
have a functional interpreter you can
see some of the other the other things I
have done here
the interpreter itself actually before
going to the interpreter it's useful to
to see to generate when you have these
grammars to kind of have an overview of
some sort of what is going on right and
you can see here with this I'm
generating 20 random sentences with the
net-net network neural network monitor
and you can see one of the commands
which you can understand I mean it some
of these are not particularly impressive
but I mean you can I mean like something
we saw earlier tree trained neural
network for whatever number of a pause
whatever matches and so forth right I
mean this case are repetitive because
when I I mean if you look at the if you
look at the options of options of net
train I mean there is no point for me
there is no order between these I need
to be able to handle all of this so I
can just have you know I just have any
kind of combination any kind of list of
possible candidates here can be used so
that's why for example we see the
repetition of this of bad size all right
well I mean similar for this
classification classification manat it's
a like you know and you can see all
these commands were being for the
classification model all these commands
interpret interpreted they are not just
first they interpreted I was showing
this earlier when I was running stuff so
I mean you can you know you can put more
complicated commands or try to consider
if you have a list of commands like can
you do something better
not just interpret them one by one but
can you actually if you know all of the
commands which are being given can you
do something something something better
this this case that what I was saying
what the interpreter is fairly easy to
do if you look at if you look at this
this pieces of code which happened from
the neural network monitor commands I'm
basically just cooking hooking up some
simple implementations very really
simple implementations of this and here
when I run this this is how I get you
know I guess I don't do it this is not
well unfortunately this is something I
didn't implement yet the decoders and
the decoders I'm going to run the net
chains and so you see this PS is having
mathematical expressions for for the for
the net chains and you can see now this
PS without the without the
interpretation right it's just a bunch
of abstract syntax trees which happened
to be called but if I put if I put
appropriate implementations to the hooks
which are represented here I'm going to
get this this neuro networks and then I
can need to drive them and do the other
stuff so ideally I want to do something
like this for the neural network monitor
I'm not sure but this is the best way
actually to do it because you see for
example here this is how I actually if I
make a full-blown conversational agent
ID for example the user doesn't need to
type this anyway but so what is
happening here I'm using I'm having
interpreted comment for the quantile
regression
monit and if I want to train the to
attach a new neural network so if I look
at this this is something we have seen
before right so this is just you know
this is a pipeline for the neural
network model but this pipeline with
this overriding here in block
I can turn it into a contour regression
pipeline and in this contour aggression
pipeline I can actually tries it to to
train the Train the expressions and
proceed further all right so what is
happening here is what at this point the
neural network conversation or agent I
don't actually it's not kind my priority
to make it to make it convenient to
construct neuro new neural networks I
want to make it convenient to be used in
larger larger kind of workflows like
workforce which are outside of the
neural networks I'm not saying I'm not
going to do it it's just not I don't see
it as a high priority as being able to
retrieve neural networks from a
repository being able to search them
this is the sparse matrix recommender
monitor on top which I didn't
demonstrate here and after you have the
monitor sorry after you have the the net
chain or net graph you actually can put
it in the classification model the CL
count at the bottom and then you can you
know produce workflows there's some and
this this here is an example of how we
can do and I need to finish here and so
basically this here this is just for a
phone book right like I have Chromebook
with a phone book with professions the
professions the occupations or the
occupations and the companies of
different type of employees and I can
say the first one and so with the third
one we are going to pick particular
person and you know and so forth and
then if I say something like say call
live I mean immediately finds a
particular person and call them so
anyway this thing here can be done for
the repository of the neural networks it
is very important when you develop this
kind of functionalities to have a lot of
unit tests this around this pipelines
they can be they need to be designed to
fail so we can I basically have two
types of for unit tests one handmade
man-made the other one is random
regenerated I generate like say 1,000
pipelines and then I see doing a family
failure if they evasive fail I try to
address it
this by the way it's extremely important
because especially if you are making
conversational agent especially if
disconnected to sound device like Alexa
you need to be able to fall gracefully
alright so you can see some of my future
plans here so one of the usual questions
when I where I discuss this approaches
but yeah but you know why are doing just
by hand why i doing why i cannot do this
to caustically cannot do it with
whatever you know like the speech neural
networks people represented well I
really don't see how they can train
automatically from a book or from a body
of text a conversational agent or any
kind of you know anything that can
generate programming code meaningful
programming code from specifications
like natural language specifications so
my approach to this is I usually program
the initial grammars like what I showed
here and then I try to extend them try
to make them fuzzier I mean obviously
you should be able to handle certain you
know mispronunciations misspellings and
etc this actually can can be done fairly
nicely this analogy with the Terminator
the terminators in the different movies
it's a it's it's apt because you start
with the rigid skeleton and then you
have just the liquid you know Terminator
but actually the best one was liquid
metal of a rigid skeleton method which
is by crystal hollow community you know
indeterminate X or neural network graphs
there's several implementations for this
to be used but I want to use it use it
from from a more general perspective I
need out of time so you can look at the
references here and you know what
basically I my big push for this
conference and this talk was to actually
make this make this pipeline work and so
and which actually doesn't for whatever
reasons because I overrode the overrode
the implementations when I was
demonstrating the expressions but this
this here it's the the current stage
where Matt and I plan to expand it
further to work with four with
classifiers with the classification
workflows not just the regression
workflow which is here and to be able to
retrieve data from the posters thank you
for your attention and if you have
questions
[Applause]